This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. On a hot summer day in 1799, French Army engineers in occupied northern Egypt were sifting through the rubble of a centuries-old abandoned fortress. These soldiers had been tasked by their general, Napoleon Bonaparte, heard of him? To repair the fort for proper use. And as they were laying the foundation for the walls and barracks, someone made a startling discovery. That's producer Vivian Ley. They stumbled upon the Rosetta Stone, possibly the most famous chunk of rock in human history.
这里是《百分之九十九隐秘》（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。1799年夏天的一个热天，在被占领的埃及北部，法国陆军的工程师们正在翻找一座废弃了几个世纪的古老堡垒的瓦砾。这些士兵受他们的将军拿破仑·波拿巴指派——听说过他吧？——去修复这座堡垒以便正常使用。正当他们为围墙和营房打地基时，有人有了一个惊人的发现。那是制作人薇薇安·莱（Vivian Ley）。他们偶然发现了罗夏石碑（译者注：原文如此，即罗塞塔石碑），这可能是人类历史上最著名的巨石。
The reason it's famous and the reason you can see it when you go to the British Museum is that there was text in three languages. That's Joel Slemrod, professor of economics at the University of Michigan. The text on the Rosetta Stone had been inscribed with the same message in three different scripts — Greek, Egyptian Demotic Scripts, and Ancient Egyptian Hieroglyphics. Which at the time no one could decipher. Based on the first two scripts, researchers were eventually able to crack the code for how to finally read hieroglyphics, a writing system that hadn't been used for about 1,400
它之所以出名，而且你参观大英博物馆时能亲眼见到它，原因在于上面刻有三种语言的文字。说话的是密歇根大学经济学教授乔尔·斯莱姆罗德（Joel Slemrod）。罗塞塔石碑上的文字是用三种不同的书写系统刻着相同的信息——希腊语、埃及世俗体和古埃及象形文字。当时没有人能解读这些文字。借助前两种文字，研究人员最终得以破解密码，从而最终能够阅读象形文字，这是一种已经有大约1400年没有被使用过的书写系统。
years. Question, what was so important to write about? And the answer is, well, among other things, the Rosetta Stone describes a tax break given to the temple priests of ancient Egypt. So the Rosetta Stone helped us unlock the secret of hieroglyphics by talking about something in Texas. Taxes are essentially as old as human civilization, and they've been shaping it ever since. Historically, they've influenced everything from what our buildings look like, to what
问题来了，上面到底写了什么这么重要？答案是，除了别的之外，罗塞塔石碑描述的是给予古埃及神庙祭司的税收减免。所以，罗塞塔石碑通过谈论德克萨斯州（译者注：播客此处玩了一个双关语/口误，将taxes（税收）谐音成了Texas（德克萨斯州））的事情，帮我们解开了象形文字的秘密。税收基本上和人类文明一样古老，而且它从那时起一直在塑造着文明。从历史上看，它们影响了一切：从我们建筑的外观，到我们驾驶的汽车类型，再到我们选举谁当总统，甚至是否会爆发起义。历史表明，税法可以揭示很多关于一个社会的信息。如果你是一个美国人，那么得到的启示就是：报个人所得税简直糟透了。如果你在这一集发布的当天收听，也就是4月15日，也就是美国所谓的“纳税日”（tax day）。我们美国人往往和我们的税收体系有着相当紧张的关系。报税流程变得如此复杂，以至于普通人要花13个小时来
kind of cars we drive, to who we elect as our president, to whether we revolt. History has shown that tax codes can reveal so much about a society. And if you're an American, the revelation is that filing our income taxes sucks. If you're listening to this episode on its release day, it is April 15th, aka tax day here in the United States. And we Americans tend to have a pretty fraught relationship with our tax system. The filing process has become so complicated that the average individual spends 13 hours
准备他们的个人所得税。当你恨不得自始至终都一拳砸向电脑屏幕时，这感觉会漫长一倍。53%的美国人对我们税收体系的复杂性感到非常烦恼。甚至有一项调查显示，它让三分之一的人“忍不住想哭”。据说连阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦也曾说过，世上最难理解的事情就是所得税。而他可是出了名的聪明。因此，在这个纳税季的最后一天，我们正在梳理近250年的美国税收历史，以弄清楚
preparing their income taxes. And that can feel twice as long when you want to put your fist through the computer screen the entire time. 53% of Americans are very bothered by the complexity of our tax system. And one survey even reported that it makes one in three people, quote, want to cry. Even Albert Einstein allegedly once said, the hardest thing in the world is to understand the income tax. And he was famously smart. So on this the final day of tax season, we are sifting through nearly 250 years of US tax history to figure out
事情怎么会变得如此该死地复杂。对税收感到愤怒是一种典型的美国体验。事实上，税收之怒是这个国家建立的一个重要原因。波士顿茶党事件是美国独立战争中的一个形成性事件。我们大多数人在初中时都学过，波士顿茶党事件是对提高茶叶税的不满而引发的反抗行为。但有趣的是，这完全是错的。实际上，事情并不是那样的。
how things got so damn complicated. Being mad about taxes is a quintessentially American experience. In fact, tax rage is a large reason why this country was created. The Boston Tea Party, a formative event in the American Revolution. Most of us learned in middle school that the Boston Tea Party was an act of defiance over an increase in taxes on tea. But fun fact, that's totally wrong. Actually though, that isn't what happened.
更接近真相的是，当时部分茶叶税其实降低了。当时，英国对茶叶征收极高的税率，以至于运往殖民地的茶叶中近三分之二都是为了避开成本而通过走私非法运入的。为了打击这种非法茶叶贸易，议会实际上降低了合法进口茶叶的税收。英国人的这些新提案似乎要剥夺一些通过走私茶叶维生的知名爱国者的生计。
Closer to the truth was that some tax on tea had been decreased. At the time, Britain had been taxing tea at such a high rate that nearly two-thirds of tea imported to the colonies was smuggled in illegally to get around the cost. In response, Parliament actually lowered taxes on legally imported tea to undercut this illicit tea trade. The new proposals from the British looked like they were going to deprive some prominent patriots of their livelihood through smuggling tea.
这让许多人感到不满。这种不满最终引发了美国独立战争和一个全新国家的诞生。鉴于过度征税是导致革命的一个巨大因素，早期美国政府在征税时非常谨慎。税收保持在很低的水平，而且极其简单。在许多许多年里，联邦收入主要来自消费税和关税等项目。
And it got a lot of people upset. That upset eventually led to the American Revolution and the founding of an entirely new country. Given that tax overreach was a huge contributing factor to the revolution, the early American government was very cautious when it came to taxation. It remained very low and extremely simple. And for many, many decades, federal revenue came mainly from things like excise taxes and tariffs.
为了明确起见，消费税适用于某些商品和服务，比如燃料。如果你不知道什么是关税，好吧，那上帝保佑你，你显然没有关注新闻。在共和国的早期，联邦支出的低足以让国家通过这种方式维持自身运转。直到突然之间，它需要更多的资金。而且要快。在内战期间，和所有战争一样，需要大量的收入。
For clarity, excise taxes are applied to certain goods and services, like fuel. And if you don't know what a tariff is, well then, bless your heart, you clearly haven't been looking at the news. In those early years of the republic, federal spending was low enough that the country could fund itself like this. Until suddenly it needed a lot more money. And fast. During the Civil War, like all wars, a lot of revenue was needed.
1862年，林肯总统签署了一项征收所得税的法律以为战争筹措资金。这实际上是美国历史上第一笔联邦所得税，甚至促成了国税局（IRS）的成立，当时被称为国内税收局（Bureau of Internal Revenue）。所得税为联邦政府筹集了5500万美元，相当于今天的约11亿美元。这是一种筹集联邦资金的创新方法。也许对那个时代来说，创新得有点过头了。
In 1862, President Lincoln signed into law an income tax to fund the war. This was actually the very first federal income tax in US history, and even led to the creation of the IRS, then called the Bureau of Internal Revenue. The income tax generated $55 million for the Union government, which was the equivalent of about $1.1 billion today. It was an innovative approach to raise federal funds. Maybe a little too innovative for its time.
果不其然，当战争在1872年左右结束时，那项所得税就被取消了。内战算是告一段落后，格兰特政府废除了大多数紧急税收，并恢复了旧的税收征收方式，即消费税，并特别关注所谓的“罪恶税”（SIN taxes）。所有联邦收入的90%来自对烈性酒、啤酒、葡萄酒和烟草的税收。尽管所得税很有效，但领导层仍然对这个想法持抵触态度。
Sure enough, when the war ended, I think, 1872, that income tax was eliminated. With the Civil War behind them, kind of, the Grant administration repealed most emergency taxes and reverted back to the old way of tax collection, excise taxes, with a special focus on what were called SIN taxes. 90% of all federal revenue came from taxes on liquor, beer, wine, and tobacco. Although the income tax was effective, leaders remained resistant to the idea.
消费税似乎足以资助政府，而且它们的实施要简单得多。它们更简单，但许多人认为它们非常不公平。消费税是累退税，这意味着它们给低收入个人带来了更高的负担。如果一个赚很少钱的人和一个赚很多钱的人支付相同的税率，那么他们支付的收入比例就会更高。大多数人会认为这是明显不公平的。因此，岁月流逝，许多人对大部分收入来自烈性酒、啤酒、葡萄酒、烟草税这一事实感到不满，而且这些负担可能主要由低收入人群承担。
Excise taxes seemed adequate to fund the government, plus they were a lot simpler to implement. They were simpler, but a lot of people thought they were very unfair. Excise taxes are regressive, meaning they place a higher burden on lower-income individuals. If someone who makes very little money is paying the same rate as someone who makes a lot of money, then they are paying a higher percentage of their income. And most people would view that as patently unfair. So years go on, and there were a lot of people who were not happy with the fact that most of the revenue is coming from taxes on liquor, beer, wine, tobacco, and probably the burden was felt heavily by lower income people.
因此，从80年代（即18世纪80年代，译者注：此处播客叙述有误，原文指1880年代）开始，尤其是90年代，出现了很多政治支持，要求实行所得税，从而减少这些其他税收。这一切都发生在镀金时代，这是一个贫富差距极大、劳动力阶层遭到剥削的时代。税收负担主要由生活在极度贫困中的绝大多数人承担。与此同时，资本大鳄（robber barons）过着奢华的生活，并与克里斯汀·芭伦斯基（Christine Baranski）等人打成一片。
So picking up in the 80s, that's the 1880s, and especially the 90s, there was a lot of political support for instituting an income tax and therefore reducing these other taxes. This was all taking place during the Gilded Age, an era of profound wealth inequality and exploitation of the labor class. The tax burden was mainly shouldered by the vast majority living in extreme poverty. Meanwhile, robber barons were living in luxury and rubbing elbows with Christine Boranski.
因此，在1894年，在逆境中，国会通过了《威尔逊-戈尔曼关税法》（Wilson-Gorman Tariff Act），实施了有史以来第一笔和平时期的所得税。这项税收专门针对富人，且只适用于任何收入超过4000美元的人，这在当时是收入最高的1%的人口。它还降低了进口关税，使其变得更便宜。因此，该法案在民主党内部赞成自由贸易的一翼中非常受欢迎。但在最高法院却很不受欢迎。
So in 1894, against the odds, Congress passed the Wilson-Gorman Tariff Act, which instituted the first-ever peacetime income tax. This tax specifically applied to the rich and only applied to anyone making over $4,000, which at the time was the highest earning 1% of the population. It also lowered tariffs on imports, making them cheaper. So the law was very popular with the pro-free trade wing of the Democratic Party. But unpopular with the Supreme Court.
最高法院裁定所得税违宪，因为，你知道的，较富裕的州的税收负担会比较穷的州更高。因此，基于这一理由，它被裁定为违宪，尽管在制宪会议期间并不清楚什么是直接税，而且直到现在对于当时的意图仍不是完全清楚。好吧，既然它违宪了。那么，如何让联邦所得税不再违宪呢？修改宪法。所得税缓缓通过了批准程序，直到最后在
The Supreme Court had ruled that an income tax was unconstitutional because, you know, richer states, the tax burden would be higher than poorer states. So on that basis, it was ruled unconstitutional, even though it wasn't clear during the Constitutional Convention what a direct tax was, and still isn't entirely clear what was meant. Okay, so it's unconstitutional. And so how do you make a federal income tax not unconstitutional? You change the constitution. The income tax slowly made its way through the ratification process until finally in
1913年，通过第十六修正案将其巩固下来。第十六修正案基本上规定，联邦政府有权征收所得税，即便所征收的税收与人口不成比例。全国性的所得税为联邦政府开辟了一个全新的收入来源，对于第一次缴纳所得税的人来说是一个巨大的改变。但几乎没有人需要报税。豁免门槛如此之高，以至于它实际上被认为是一种阶级税（class tax），而不是大众税（mass tax），因为它适用的范围太小了。
1913, it was solidified by the 16th Amendment. And the 16th Amendment basically says the federal government has the right to levy an income tax even though the revenues collected would not be proportional to population. The national income tax opened up the federal government to a whole new source of income and was a huge change for people filing an income tax for the first time. But barely anyone had to file one. The exemption level was so high that it was actually thought of as a class tax, not a mass tax, because it applied to so few people.
因此，在1913年，豁免门槛是3000美元。好吧，这大约相当于当今美元的90,000美元左右。所以在1913年，大约提交了350,000份纳税申报表。那是在一个人口略低于1亿的国家。所得税不仅只影响极小一部分人口，而且其中涉及的 paperwork（文书工作）也简单得令人赞叹。作为一个税务书呆子（tax nerd），你不会惊讶地发现我的办公室里框着一份原始税表的复印件。
So in 1913, the exemption level was $3,000. Okay, that's about $90,000 in today's dollars, approximately. So in 1913, about 350,000 returns were filed. And that's in a country with a population just under 100 million. Not only did the income tax only impact a narrow fraction of the population, the paperwork involved was wonderfully uncomplicated. As a tax nerd, you won't be surprised to know I have a copy of the original tax form framed in my office.
新所得税的申报表格——这就是表格和说明——长达四页。尽管这四页的表格非常简陋，但到了第二年，一些人已经在谴责它的复杂性了。在年度税务会议上，一位发言者宣称：“联邦所得税需要简化，这一点是无可否认的。”
The filing form of the new income tax was, and this is the form and the instructions, four pages long. Despite how sparse the four-page form was, by the following year, some were already decrying its complexity. At the annual conference on taxation, one speaker declared, It will hardly be denied that the federal income tax needs simplification.
“它的复杂性是其显著特征。首先，法案所用的语言盘根错节，辞藻令人眼花缭乱。它的术语令人困惑。”但当然，就复杂性而言，此后只会一路走高。短短几十年后，美国迎来了一个彻底改变所得税的转折点。昨天，1941年12月7日，一个遗臭万年的日子。因此，当我们谈论时，显而易见的是，战争在税收的故事中扮演了重要角色。在二战期间，税收发生了非常急剧的变化。
Its complexity is its distinguishing characteristic. To begin with, the language in which the act is couched is involved, and its rhetoric bewildering. Its terminology is confusing. But of course, in terms of complexity, it was only uphill from there. And just a few decades later, the U.S. reached an inflection point that changed the income tax for good. Yesterday, December 7th, 1941, a date which will live in infamy. So as we're talking, it's clear that wars play a big part in the story of taxation. It changed very precipitously in World War II.
战争的绝对规模意味着美国人将面临前所未有的征税。一方面，报税的豁免门槛被大幅降低，这意味着很大一部分人口实际上必须处理它。1939年，提交了770万份申报表，对吧？六年后的数字是4990万。所以这增加了六倍多。这就是巨大的变化。
The sheer scale of the war meant that Americans would be taxed like never before. For one, the exemption level for filing taxes was lowered way down, meaning a lot more of the population actually had to deal with it. In 1939, 7.7 million returns were filed, okay? Six years later, 49.9 million. So that's an increase of more than six times. So that was the big change.
它正式从一种阶级税变成了一种大众税。财政部将其宣传为我们对战争努力的爱国责任去报税。他们甚至委托欧文·柏林（Irving Berlin）为此谱写了一首轻快的曲子。我和美国扯平了。你看到天上的那些轰炸机了吗。洛克菲勒帮忙建造了它们，我也一样。我今天交了所得税。
It officially went from being a class tax to a mass tax. And the Department of Treasury plugged it as our patriotic duty to the war effort to file our taxes. They even commissioned Irving Berlin to compose a jaunty little number about it. I'm squared up with the USA. You see those bombers in the sky. Rockefeller helped to build them, so did I. I paid my income tax today.
我今天交了所得税。在这个时期演变的不仅仅是税基。我们征税的方式也发生了改变。1943年之前，个人每年申报一次他们所欠的一笔总税款。理想情况下，纳税人会提前计划并在全年存够钱，以便在春天申报并缴纳税款。但在1943年，联邦政府改变了规则。它说，不，现在雇主必须在你赚钱的同时将钱汇给政府。
I paid my income tax today. And it wasn't just the tax base that evolved during this time. The way we collected them changed as well. Before 1943, individuals filed once a year for the one lump sum that they owed. Ideally, taxpayers would plan ahead and save enough all year in order to file and pay their taxes in the spring. But 1943, the federal government changed the rules. It said, no, now the employers have to be sending money to the government while you're earning it.
如果你作为企业、公司或政府机构的雇员谋生，你知道的，向老板汇报工作，那么你已经完全清楚雇主代扣代缴（employer withholding）制度。法律要求你的雇主从你的工资中扣除一部分，用来缴纳你所欠的税款。这是所得税系统运作方式的一个重大改变。这在几个非常重要的方面使税收征管实现了现代化。首先，大多数公民不再每年一次被巨额税单砸中，因为他们已经通过工资支票按比例分期缴纳了。此外，需要追查的人也变少了。
If you earn a living as an employee of a business or a corporation or a government agency, you know, you report to the man, then you are already fully aware of employer withholding. Your employer is required by law to withhold a portion of your wages to pay into taxes you owe. That was a major change in how the income tax system worked. This modernized tax collection in some very important ways. For one, most citizens stopped being slammed by a larger tax bill once a year, since they were already paying into it incrementally through their paychecks. Also, there were fewer people to shake down.
这大大降低了行政负担以及国税局（IRS）的负担。他们不必去追踪所有的雇员。但历史表明，这是税收体系运作方式中最大的创新。世界上几乎所有实行所得税的国家都在这样做。当二战结束、政府开支下降时，你可能会期望所得税再次被废除，就像内战后发生的那样。但相反，它只是留了下来。二战后税收水平并没有急剧下降，有时被称为棘轮效应（ratchet effect）。
It makes the administrative burden and the burden on the IRS much lower. They don't have to track down all the employees. But history shows that this has been the biggest innovation in how tax systems work. Almost every country of the world with an income tax does this. When World War II ended and government spending declined, you might have expected the income tax to be abolished once again, like what happened after the Civil War. But instead, it just stuck around. The level of tax didn't decline precipitously after World War II, sometimes called the ratchet
而且，你知道的，为什么会这样并不完全清楚。你知道，有一种说法是人们已经对它习惯了。政府在二战期间在这方面变得很熟练，所以它留了下来，并从那时起一直留存至今。战争期间，联邦政府的角色永久性地扩大了，这使得回到旧的税收结构变得不可能。从增加社会保障到《退伍军人权利法案》（GI bill）再到国防开支，政府支出大幅增加。
effect. And, you know, why that happened is not entirely known. You know, one story is that people had become familiar with it. The government had gotten good at it during World War II, and so it stuck around and has stuck around since then. During the war, the role of the federal government had permanently expanded in a way that made going back to the old tax structure impossible. Government spending had ramped up from increased Social Security to the GI bill to defense
因此，所征收和支出的资金数额出现了巨大的增长。二战后，一直到20世纪50年代和60年代初，美国和英国的最高所得税率超过了90%。薇薇安，我不知道你是不是流行音乐的粉丝，但披头士乐队有一首歌叫《税务员》（The Taxman），对吧？给你一个，十九个给我，我是税务员。所以那是95%的税率。二战使缴纳所得税成为几乎每个美国人的问题。
spending. So it's just been a huge increase in the amount of money collected and spent. After World War II, up to the 50s and early 60s, the top rate of income tax in the US and in the UK was over 90%. Vivian, I don't know if you're a fan of popular music, but the Beatles had a song, The Taxman, right? It's one for you, 19 for me, I'm the taxman. So that's a 95% rate. World War II made filing income taxes nearly every American's problem.
但报税成为一个更加复杂的问题，有两个主要原因。一个原因是，二战后，政策制定者越来越多地开始利用税法来对纳税人的行为进行社会工程学改造（socially engineer）。毫无疑问，税收体系会影响行为，立法者已经注意到了这一点，税收体系中有很多东西。
But there were two big reasons why filing taxes became a much more complicated problem. One reason is that after World War II, policymakers more and more started using the tax code to socially engineer taxpayer behavior. There's no question that the tax system can affect behavior, and legislators have noticed this, and there's a lot of things in the tax system,
它们的设立并不是特别为了让税收体系更公平，而是为了改变人们的行为。利用税法来引导行为并不是美国的新发明或特例。事实上，从历史上看，它曾被用于某些相当离奇的方式。在俄罗斯，彼得大帝在将俄罗斯现代化得更像西欧时，他注意到俄罗斯的贵族留着这种满脸的大胡子，而在西欧，那已经有点过时了。
which are there not particularly to make the tax system fairer, but to change people's behavior. Using tax law to drive behavior was not new or unique to the United States. In fact, historically, it's been used in some kind of bizarre ways. In Russia, Peter the Great, when he was modernizing Russia to look more like Western Europe, he noticed that the nobility in Russia had these full beards in Western Europe. That was kind of out.
所以他做了什么？他本可以禁止留胡子，你知道的，禁止拥有胡子，但他巧妙地对胡子征税。因此，如果你带着胡子出现在公共场合，你必须佩戴一枚小奖章，作为你支付了胡子税的证明。在二战后的美国，所得税现在适用于更多的人，以至于它成为立法者将大众引导至某些对社会有益的行为的有用工具。税收抵免可以鼓励你为退休储蓄，或者阻止你购买燃气动力汽车，或者鼓励你翻新历史建筑，或者阻止你购买烟草和酒精。
And so what did he do? He could have banned beards, you know, having a beard, but instead he cleverly had a tax on beards. So if you were out in public with a beard, you had to have a little medallion that was proof that you'd paid your beard tax. In post-World War II America, the income tax now applied to so many more people that it became a useful tool for lawmakers to nudge the masses into certain socially beneficial behaviors. Tax credits can encourage you to save for retirement, or discourage you from buying a gas-powered vehicle, or encourage you to renovate a historic building, or discourage you from buying a gas powered vehicle or encourage you to renovate a historic building or discourage you from buying tobacco and alcohol.
所得税法变得如此复杂的另一个重要原因，具有讽刺意味的是出于一个非常简单的原因：因为我们希望它是公平的。我们的税收体系，任何税收体系都可以变得简单得多，但我认为，在决定多大程度上简化的过程中，所涉及的问题最好通过讨论你能想到的最简单的税收体系来阐明。我能想到的最简单的税收体系是经济学家所说的“总额税”（lump sum tax）。总额税基本上是每个人欠下的相同固定金钱金额，无论他们赚多少钱。这将是非常简单的。为什么这永远不会发生？
Another big reason why the income tax code has become so complex is ironically for a very simple reason because we want it to be fair. Our tax system, any tax system could be made much simpler, but the issues in deciding how much simpler, I think, are best illustrated by talking about what's the simplest tax system you can think of. The simplest tax system I can think of is what economists call a lump sum tax. A lump sum tax is basically the same flat monetary amount owed by every person, regardless of how much they make. It would be darn simple. Why would this never happen?
因为大多数人会发现这完全不公平，美国最富有的一个人所欠的税款竟然和一个苦苦挣扎的单身母亲完全一样。我们在美国没有总额税。我们拥有累进税（progressive tax），即我们的税率随着收入的增加而提高。但即使那样也没有真正考虑到公平。有人会说，嗯，这还不够。某个人的收入和另一个人一样，但有大量的医疗费用，他们的境况其实并没有那么好。
Because most people would find that to be completely unfair that the richest person in America owes exactly the same tax as a single mother struggling to get by. We do not have a lump sum tax here in the United States. We have a progressive tax where our tax rate increases alongside our income. But even that doesn't truly account for fairness. Somebody says, well, that's not enough. Somebody with the same income as somebody else but with a lot of medical expenses, they're not really as well off.
好吧，那我们就为医疗费用提供一项扣除（deduction）。更复杂，以此类推。我们越是试图微调税收体系的公平性，这不可避免地就会让它变得更复杂。这就引发了一连串的问题，比如：一个抚养三个孩子的单身母亲难道不应该比一个没有孩子的单身人士获得更多的退税吗？或者你可以扣除赎金吗？或者为什么一个捕鲸船船长必须和航海爱好者的船长支付相同的金额，既然它是一笔商业开支？
All right, so let's have a deduction for medical expenses. More complicated and dot dot dot. The more we try to fine tune the fairness of the tax system, that inevitably makes it more complicated. This opens the door to a lot of questions like, doesn't a single mother of three deserve a larger tax refund than a single person with no children? Or can you deduct a ransom payment? Or why should a whaling ship captain have to pay the same amount as a sailing hobbyist when it's a business expense?
我们的税收体系是否真的公平是另一回事。但我们不断地对其进行修补，以应对这些独特的问题和情况。正是这种对公平的永恒追求以及由此产生的抵免、扣除和豁免，将我们的税法推向了一个迷宫般的境地。最初在1913年只有四页的1040表，到2025年已经变成了一份高达106页的文件。嗯，我认为它本可以也应该更简单。我认为倾向于过多地试图为公平而微调税收体系，以及
Whether or not our tax system is actually fair is a whole other story. But we are constantly tinkering with it to account for these unique questions and circumstances It is the eternal struggle for fairness and the resulting credits and deductions and exemptions That has ratcheted our tax code into a labyrinthian experience the form 1040 which started out as four pages in 1913 has become a whopping 106 page document in 2025. Well, I think it could and should be simpler. I think the tendency is too much to try to fine tune the tax system for fairness and
利用税收体系来改变行为和激励各种事情的趋势有点过头了。我认为我们走得稍微有点远了。因此我会认真考虑让税收体系比现在更简单。为了改革我们的税法，有过大量的尝试，成功程度不一，政策制定者将继续为最好的做法争论不休，直到时间的尽头。美国拥有一个复杂的经济，在很大程度上需要复杂的税法。
to use the tax system to change behavior and incentivize various things. I think we've gone a little bit too far. So I would take seriously making the tax system simpler than it is now. There have been plenty of attempts to reform our tax code with varying levels of success and policymakers will continue fighting over the best ways to do it until the end of time. The United States has a complex economy that, for the most part, requires complicated tax law.
但这并不意味着我们有一个错综复杂的税法，普通美国人在浏览它时就必须受苦。政府可以让所得税申报流程变得简单得多，而在许多其他国家，情况恰恰如此。所以在许多国家，大多数家庭不必提交纳税申报表。包括英国、西班牙、丹麦和爱沙尼亚在内的36个国家，都有一种名为“免申报报税”（return-free filing）系统的变体。情况是这样的：到了纳税年度之后的1月或2月，他们会收到政府的一封电子邮件，上面写着：
But just because we have a convoluted tax code doesn't necessarily mean that average Americans need to suffer while navigating it. The government could make the income tax filing process a lot simpler, and in a lot of other countries, that's exactly what happens. So in a lot of countries, most households don't have to file tax returns. Thirty-six countries, including the UK, Spain, Denmark, and Estonia, all have a variation of a system called return-free filing. What happens is, come January or February after the tax year, they get an email from the government and it says,
嘿，我们已经从你的雇主和银行等地获取了信息。根据我们所知的信息，这是你的纳税申报表，这是你欠的税款。所以我们要求的全部就是请你过目。如果我们全算对了，你知道的，点击这个框，你就完成了。当然，美国的税法漫长、曲折而复杂。但还有很多其他国家的税法同样复杂，却让纳税人的报税变得更容易、免费。在美国，国税局已经掌握了预先填写我们税表所需的许多信息，这可以为我们节省大量的时间和金钱。这听起来像是税务申报系统中一个非常重要的简化。
hey, we've gotten information from your employer and your bank, etc. And based on what we know, here's what your tax return looks like, and here's what you owe. So all we ask you to do is look it over. If we got it all right, you know, click this box and you're done. Of course, the tax code in the United States is long, winding and complex. But there are plenty of other countries with complicated tax codes that have made filing easier and free for taxpayers. In the U.S., the IRS already has a lot of the information needed to prepopulate our tax forms for us, which could save us a ton of time and money. That sounds like a pretty important simplification in the tax filing system.
你可以猜到谁会觉得这不是个好主意。是税务软件的制造商。税务软件提供商和相关的特殊利益集团有着既得利益，希望让税表尽可能复杂和令人望而生畏。在没有专业人士帮助的情况下申报个人所得税是令人生畏的。2024年的一项调查表明，44%的美国人计划使用H&R Block或TurboTax等公司提供的税务软件，以理清这种混乱。出售税务软件的公司在税制
And you can guess who doesn't think it's a good idea. It's the makers of tax software. Tax software providers and related special interest groups have a vested interest in keeping tax forms as intricate and intimidating as possible. Filing an income tax without the help of a professional is daunting. A 2024 survey indicated that 44 percent of Americans plan to use tax software provided by companies like H&R Block or TurboTax in order to cut through that confusion. The companies that sell tax software do better when the tax system
复杂时获益更多，因为随着系统变复杂，你会担心自己做得不对，担心自己没有获得应得的所有抵免和扣除。ProPublica报道称，几十年来，TurboTax的母公司Intuit花费了数千万美元游说反对那些本可以使普通美国人的报税变得免费和容易的新税收系统。在这个问题上，除了时间和金钱之外，还有另一个成本。提交个人所得税申报表是普通美国人
is complicated because if as it gets complicated you worry you're not doing it right and you worry you're not getting every all the credits and deductions you deserve. ProPublica reported that for decades Intuit, the parent company of TurboTax, has spent tens of millions of dollars lobbying against new tax systems that would have made filing free and easy for average Americans. There's also another cost outside of time and money when it comes to this issue. Filing an income tax return is one of the most common ways that the average American
与联邦政府直接互动的最常见方式之一。当这种互动成为一种长期糟糕的体验时，人们就会失去对政府的信任。尽管遭到抵抗，过去几年在改变纳税人体验方面还是采取了一些重大举措。其中一项进展尤其令人瞩目。一项新工具从今年开始推出，让您报税更轻松。纳税人可以使用一种名为“IRS Direct File Tool”（国税局直接报税工具）的东西。它是免费的、用户友好的，这项在线服务允许符合条件的……
directly interacts with the federal government. When that interaction is a perpetually bad experience, people lose trust in the government. Despite the resistance, there have been some major moves over the past few years to transform the taxpayer experience. One development in particular has been especially promising. And a new tool is available to make filing your own taxes easier starting this year. Taxpayers have access to something called the IRS Direct File Tool. It's free, user-friendly, the online service allows eligible...
在2024年，国税局在12个州推出了直接报税试点项目，允许符合条件的纳税人在不使用商业报税软件的情况下免费以电子方式提交申报表。参与者最快可在30分钟内完成申报，86%的受访者表示，“直接报税”增强了他们对国税局的信任。该项目被普遍视为让广大美国人的报税变得更简单、更便宜的一个良好开端。
In 2024, the IRS rolled out a direct file pilot program in 12 states, which allowed qualifying taxpayers to file returns electronically for free without the use of commercial tax prep software. Participants were able to file in as little as 30 minutes, and 86% of respondents reported that direct file increased their trust in the IRS. The program has been widely seen as a good start for making taxes a lot simpler and a lot cheaper for a wide swath of Americans.
但不幸的是，它确实面临着一场艰难的战斗。埃隆·马斯克（Elon Musk）的电锯割向了数千名国税局员工，这是最新的牺牲品。就在数百万美国人准备报税之际，这轮裁员本周波及了该机构10万名员工中约7%的人。尽管财政部长承诺在2025年税收截止日期前保留甚至扩大直接报税项目，但其长期前景仍不确定。国会共和党人和私人税务公司批评该项目是不必要的、
But unfortunately, it does face an uphill battle. The latest casualties of Elon Musk chainsaw thousands of IRS workers. The layoffs hit roughly 7% of the agency's 100,000-person workforce this week, just as millions of Americans prepare to file their taxes. Although the Treasury Secretary committed to keeping and even expanding the direct file program through the 2025 tax deadline, its long-term future is uncertain. Congressional Republicans and private tax firms have criticized the program as unnecessary
不可持续的。埃隆·马斯克甚至发帖称，他已经，引用原话，“删除了”负责该项目的政府机构。所以鬼才知道会发生什么。在我们知道鬼会发生什么之前，每年的4月15日，申报所得税将继续让我、三分之一的美国人和阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦一起想要哭泣。我们本该现在就报税的。对于那些还没报税的人，你有什么建议吗？
and unsustainable. Elon Musk even posted that he had already, quote, deleted the government agency that worked on the program. So who the hell knows what will happen. And until we know what the hell will happen, every April 15, filing an income tax will continue making me want to cry alongside a third of Americans and Albert Einstein. We're supposed to be doing our taxes right now. Do you have any tips for people who have not done their taxes just yet?
不，我没有。正如我所说，我不是律师。我是一名经济学家。所以我想我对你没有任何建议。乔尔·斯莱姆罗德是密歇根大学的经济学教授，也是《叛乱、恶棍与收入：历代税收趣事与智慧》（Rebellion Rascals and Revenue Tax Follies and Wisdom Through the Ages）一书的合著者。如果你是99PI的粉丝，我强烈建议你去看看，因为这绝对符合你的胃口。当我们从广告休息回来后，库尔特·科尔施泰特（Kurt Kohlstedt）将带来建筑文摘式的游览，介绍税收是如何塑造世界建筑的。请继续收听。所以我们在薇薇安关于税法的报道中简要提到的一件事是，税收影响了我们建筑的外观。
No, I don't. As I said, I'm not a lawyer. I'm an economist. So I guess I don't have any tips for you. Joel Slimrod is a professor of economics at the University of Michigan and the co-author of the book Rebellion Rascals and Revenue Tax Follies and Wisdom Through the Ages. If you're a 99PI fan, I highly suggest you check it out because it is right up your alley. When we come back from the break, Kurt Kohlstedt gives an architectural digest tour of how taxes have shaped the world's buildings. Stay with us. So one of the things we mentioned briefly in Vivian's piece about tax code was that taxation influenced what our buildings look like.
所以我在这里和99PI自己的柯克·科尔斯塔德（Kirk Kolstad）一起讨论这个问题，探讨我们周围的建筑环境是如何被税收塑造的。是的，没错，罗曼。我们倾向于认为建筑是地方风格和建筑设计师的产物，也许在更世俗的方面，比如某些材料的可用性和成本，
And so I'm here with 99PI's own Kirk Kolstad to talk about that, how the built environment around us was shaped by taxation. Yeah, that's right, Roman. And we tend to think of buildings as being the product of regional styles and architectural designers, and maybe on the more mundane side, things like the availability and cost of certain materials
或者当然还有建筑规范，但税法可以在建筑上留下长达数个世纪的不可思议的印记。好的，给我们举个例子吧。好吧，独立战争后，英国背负了巨额债务。因此，乔治三世国王在1784年推出了英国砖税（brick tax），旨在增加收入并偿还这些债务，
or of course building codes, but tax code can leave incredible marks on buildings that last for centuries. Okay, give us an example. Well, after the Revolutionary War, Britain was massively in debt. So King George III introduced the British brick tax in 1784 to like raise revenue and pay off those bills,
当然，砖匠们得知了这一点，他们发现按每块砖来征税。因此，他们做出的反应只是制作更大的砖块。对。所以有了更大的砖块，你就可以用更少的砖块建造同样大的墙。因此，你某种程度上，你支付的是相同的，你知道的，每单位税收，但你得到了，你知道的，更大的建筑。更多的材料。是的，完全正确。是的。是的。这就是主意。但当然，英国王室识破了这一点，并作出了反应，既增加了每块砖的税收，还增加了一项针对超过一定大小的砖块的税收。
and of course brick makers, they learned of this, and they saw that they'd be taxed on a per brick basis. And so they responded by simply making bigger bricks. Right. And so with bigger bricks, you can make as big a wall with fewer bricks. And therefore you're sort of, you're paying the same, you know, per unit tax, but you get, you know, a bigger building. More material. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's the idea. But of course, the Crown caught on to this and responded both by increasing the taxes per brick, but also adding a tax
这一举措实际上导致一些企业倒闭，因为他们负担不起更高的税收。他们手头有所有这些较大的库存，却根本无法支付。但那个时代制造的许多较大砖块流传于世，至今仍可在建筑上看到。在某些情况下，你甚至可以在一面墙上同时看到税前
for bricks above a certain size. And this move actually caused some businesses to go under because they couldn't afford the higher taxes. They had all this larger stock on hand and they just couldn't pay that. But a lot of those larger bricks made during that era, made it out into the world and can be seen on buildings to this day. And in some cases, you can even see both the pre-tax
和税后的砖块。所以我刚刚给你看了这张英格兰一条商业街（high street）的照片。也许你可以描述一下你看到了什么。好的。所以有高街的标志。这是一堵砖墙。有一条垂直的线将墙分成两部分。在一侧，砖块要大得多，
and the post-tax bricks on a single wall. So I just shared you this photo of a high street in England. And maybe you can just describe what you're seeing. Sure. So there's the sign high street. It's a brick wall. And there's a vertical line dividing two parts of the wall. And on one side, the bricks are quite a bit larger
比起另一侧，较小的一侧。有点像马赛克的一侧和大砖块的一侧。是的，完全是这样。所以你可以想象，一个历史学家可以字面意义上地只需看一眼这个，就能明白墙的这一部分可以追溯到这个时代，而墙的这一部分，
than the other side, the smaller side. There's kind of a mosaic side and the kind of big brick side. Yeah, yeah, totally. And so you can imagine like a historian can literally just look at this and understand that like this part of the wall dates back to this era and this part of the wall,
你知道的，它追溯到一个不同的时代，仅仅通过观察砖块的大小。太酷了。好吧，你还有什么要告诉我们的吗？嗯，几年后，英国立法者引入了一项每扇窗户征税的税（per window tax）。是的，如果这遵循砖税的逻辑，你就会有像非常大的窗户，
you know, it dates back to a different era just from looking at the brick sizes. That's so cool. Okay, what else do you have for us? Well, a few years later, British lawmakers introduced a per window tax. Yeah, and if this follows the same logic of the brick tax, you would just have like really big windows,
我想我没见过。不，不，可惜没有。我猜那会贵得离谱。因此，人们实际上只是开始用木板封上甚至用砖砌上他们认为不那么重要的窗户。尽管这项税收早已被废除，但你仍然可以在全国各地看到
which I don't think I've seen. No, no, alas no. I imagine that would have been super expensive. And so instead people actually just started boarding or even bricking up the windows that they considered like less important. And even though that tax has like long since been repealed, you can still see windows around the country
在那一时期被砖封上的窗户。是的，因为那是容易做到的事情，但撤销却有点难。对，对。因为那样你就得安装一扇窗户，对吧？ exatamente（没错）。是的，是的。所以我猜这也是其中的一部分。
that were bricked up in that era. Yeah, because that's something that's easy to do, but that's kind of hard to undo. Right, right. Because then you have to install a window, right? Exactly. Yeah, yeah. And so I imagine that's part of it.
然后，在某些情况下，我可以看到人们只是习惯了，对吧？比如那些区域在几个世纪里变成了墙，所以它们完全承担了不同的用途。而那些被认为是次要的窗户，所以这说得通。现在我们一直在谈论英国，但在某些地方，比如阿姆斯特丹，
And then in some cases, I could see people just getting used to it, right? Like those areas have become walls over the centuries, and so they've just taken on a completely different use. And those were deemed the least important windows, so that would make sense. Now we've been talking a lot about Britain, but in some places, like Amsterdam,
税收确实从根本上塑造了整个城市的性格，我具体指的是那些阿姆斯特丹非常著名的、非常醒目的运河房屋。是的，这些太美了。它们就像这些超级薄的建筑物。它们通常像四层，
taxation has really fundamentally shaped the entire character of the city, and I'm specifically referring to those really prominent canal houses for which Amsterdam is really well known. Yeah, these are beautiful. They're like these super thin buildings. They're usually like four,
也许五层高，上下浮动。它们沿着运河的许多街区并排而坐，挨家挨户。在它们的狭窄和拥挤之间，我的意思是，我觉得它们很可爱，像童话书一样美丽。绝对的。它们看起来就像童话里的东西。
maybe five stories tall, give or take. And they sit, you know, side by side, like wall to wall along a lot of blocks in canals. And between their narrowness and their crowdedness, I mean, I find them like delightful, like storybook, beautiful. Absolutely. They look like something out of a fairy tale.
人们可以说它们是阿姆斯特丹最鲜明的物理特征。参观这座城市的人可以环顾四周，看到它们在某种程度上是多么一致，并可能想象有一个总体规划来把整个城市建成这样。或者也许只有建筑规范说，你必须有这种形状之类的。
And one could argue that they're like the most defining physical feature of Amsterdam. And somebody visiting the city could look around, see like how consistent they are in a certain way, and maybe imagine that there was a master plan to build the whole city like this. Or maybe there are just building codes that say, you have to have this kind of shape or whatever.
但不是，是税收。阿姆斯特丹选择根据建筑物正面立面的宽度来对建筑物征税。哇。一旦你知道了这一点，这一切就都讲得通了，因为那一项税收鼓励人们建造我们今天看到的东西。非常瘦削的建筑物，
But no, it was taxes. Amsterdam chose to tax buildings based on the width of a building's front facade. Wow. And once you know that, it all makes sense because that one tax encouraged people to build exactly what we see today. Really skinny buildings,
作为住宅来说相当高，你知道的，相当多的楼层，而且，你知道的，它们真的很深，尽可能向后延伸以获得最大空间，但宽度最小，从而减少了它们的税收。没错，一切都归结于底线。然后由于这种狭窄，内部的楼梯也变得非常狭窄。这使得将家具搬上去或将货物搬上去存放在更高楼层变得困难，在某些情况下甚至不可能。所以这些建筑物的另一个标志性标志
pretty tall for a residential place, you know, quite a few stories, and, you know, they're really deep, they go back as far as possible to get the maximum space they can, but with minimum width, so therefore reducing their taxes. Exactly, it's all about the bottom line. And then as a result of this thinness, the interior staircases became really narrow too. And that made it difficult, if not impossible in some cases, to bring furniture up or carry up goods to be like stored on higher levels. So another iconic feature of these buildings
是这些凸出在人行道上方的起重和滑轮系统。它们就坐在最顶端山墙屋顶的正下方。而且它们非常引人注目。对，这些是因为，假设你搬了一个巨大的沙发，或者一袋沉重的谷物什么的，我不知道。但你只要在上面挂一根绳子，然后把它拉上去，
are these hoist and pulley systems that stick out over the sidewalks. And they sit right below like the gabled roof at the very top. And they're very prominent. Right, and these are because, say you got this gigantic couch to move, or a heavy sack of grain or whatever, I don't know. But you just hook a rope on it, and you pull it up,
然后把它荡进一个高层的窗户里。是的，是的，完全正确。在过去的几个世纪里，其中一些已经被拆除了，但许多仍然存在，有些纯粹是装饰性的，但其他的仍然在使用，因为约束条件并没有改变，对吧？
and then you swing it into an upper know, like into an upper story window. Yeah, yeah, exactly. And some of those have been removed to, you know, in the intervening centuries, but a lot of them are still around and some are purely decorative, but others are still very much in use because it's not like the constraints have changed, right?
它们仍然有这些非常狭窄的楼梯，人们仍然真的很需要家具。如果我住在那些建筑物里，我绝对会让起重机保持工作状态。哦，是的。我的意思是，它真的很像，它是建筑物的一个标志性部分。它和建筑物的狭窄一样具有标志性。
They still have these really narrow staircases and people still really need furniture. And if I lived in one of those buildings, I would totally keep the hoist in working order. Oh yeah. I mean, it's really like, it's a kind of iconic part of the building. It's as iconic as the narrowness of the building.
是的，这就是这一切对我来说最疯狂的地方，因为你拥有这个美丽的运河城市，它以这个令人惊叹的建筑吸引着游客。而且，你知道的，很容易想象它是精确规划到每一个细节的。就像他们打算拥有这些狭窄的建筑物，他们打算拥有这些起重系统一样。但就像其中的大部分一样，这一切都是由税收驱动的。
Yeah, and that's what's wild about all of this to me because you've got this beautiful canal city and it draws tourists for this amazing architecture. And you know, it would be easy to imagine that it was planned down to every detail. Like they intended to have these narrow buildings and they intended to have these hoist systems. But like so much of it, like it's all driven by taxation.
是的，这正是我觉得这一切最不可思议的地方，因为你拥有这样一座美丽的运河城市，它以惊人的建筑吸引着游客。你知道的，人们很容易想象它是经过方方面面精心规划的。就像他们本意就是要建造这些狭窄的建筑物，本意就是要安装这些起吊系统一样。但事实并非如此，这一切其实都是由税收驱动的。
Right, and these types of stories like excite you. We have a whole book full of them. It's called 99% Invisible City that Kurt and I co-authored about five years ago at this point. It's like the five-year anniversary. Yeah, it's coming up on that five-year anniversary. And we're going to have some special content around that too, but I'm going to keep that piece a surprise.
没错，这类故事能让你兴奋。我们有一整本书都是关于这些的。它叫做《99%隐形城市》，大约在五年前由我和库尔特共同撰写。这就像是五周年纪念日。是的，五周年纪念日快到了。我们也会围绕这个推出一些特别的内容，不过我要把那部分留作惊喜。
Excellent. But in the meantime, you can go check out the 99% Invisible City or just keep listening to the show. We'll talk about this stuff again. As always, we'll keep nerding out about this. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Vivian Ley and edited by Delaney Hall, mixed by Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Real and APM. Fact-checking by Graham Hayesha. Again, Joel Slemrod's book is called Rebellion Rascals and Revenue Tax Follies and Wisdom Through the Ages. There's a ton of really fun, very 99PI tax stories in there that we didn't get to that
太棒了。但与此同时，你可以去看看《99%隐形城市》，或者继续收听这个节目。我们还会再次讨论这些内容。和往常一样，我们会继续对此深入钻研。《99%隐形之城》本周由维维安·莱（Vivian Ley）制作，德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）剪辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzalez）混音，音乐由斯旺·雷尔（Swan Real）和APM提供。事实核查由格雷厄姆·海耶沙（Graham Hayesha）负责。再次说明，乔尔·斯姆罗德（Joel Slemrod）的书名为《叛乱、恶棍与税收：历代的税收蠢事与智慧》（Rebellion Rascals and Revenue Tax Follies and Wisdom Through the Ages）。里面有大量非常有趣、极具99PI风格的税收故事，我们没能讲到，
we know you'll love. Oh, this is really important. 99% Invisible is up for three Webby Awards this year, and I'm really feeling the need to win them. We're up for Best Arts and Culture Podcast for the Power Brokers series, Best Arts and Culture episode for Rocketman that was produced by Chris Perube, and Best Limited Series for the Power Brokers series, best arts and culture episode for Rocket Man that was produced by Chris Berube, and best limited series for the Power Brokers series. We'll have a link in the show notes to the Webby Awards, or you can just search for Webby Awards and then search for 99 to get to our categories.
我们知道你们一定会喜欢。哦，这非常重要。《99%隐形》今年入围了三项威比奖（Webby Awards），我真的非常希望能赢得它们。我们入围的奖项包括：凭借“权力掮客”（Power Brokers）系列入围“最佳艺术与文化播客”，凭借由克里斯·佩鲁韦（Chris Perube）制作的“火箭人”（Rocketman）入围“最佳艺术与文化单集”，以及凭借“权力掮客”系列入围“最佳有限剧集”；凭借由克里斯·贝鲁比（Chris Berube）制作的“火箭人”入围最佳艺术与文化单集，以及凭借“权力掮客”系列入围最佳有限剧集。我们将在节目说明中提供通往威比奖的链接，或者你也可以直接搜索威比奖，然后搜索“99”来找到我们的分类。
Thank you so much. Kathie Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Kohlstedt is the digital director, the rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Lashma Don, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. InBeautiful, Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us all on Blue Sky as well as our own Discord server, there's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
非常感谢。凯西·图（Kathie Tu）是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯特ッド（Kurt Kohlstedt）是数字总监，团队其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁比、杰森·德莱昂、埃mett·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、拉什玛·唐、乔·罗森伯格、凯利·普赖姆、雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森，还有我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。《99%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。我们现在是SiriusXM播客大家庭的一部分，总部位于潘多拉大楼（Pandora building）以北六个街区。位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区。你可以在Blue Sky以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们，节目说明里有指向该服务器的链接，以及99PI所有往期节目的链接，网址是99PI.org。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。